bang-bang what's up guys welcome to
lunch money while Wall Street is trying
to get rich the rest of us just trying
to get our lunch money right coming to
you everyday noon issue is because we
don't have our [ __ ] together before noon
afternoon right at noon or at 5:00 p.m.
the beautiful miss Polina will be with
me talking about current events maybe a
few laughs in between before we get into
anything though we have a problem
Polina is now trying to do
advertisements without paying for the
advertisements so go and sign up for her
newsletter the profile at read the
profile calm are you happy
okay now let's actually get to the real
information today self-made what
self-made so guys we've been watching
self-made on we watched it already
though it's not we're watching it's over
okay we just finished watching self-made
on Netflix and it's really really good
it's it's a miniseries inspired by the
life of madam CJ Walker he kept calling
her madam madam madam madam sounds
better it says more like powerful magong
well she is the first female millionaire
in the United States and she did it with
a haircare treatment for women okay well
there's a lot more to story than that so
she's an african-american woman who in
the time of I think it was right around
when slavery was just ND and people it
had ended okay and she basically saw all
these beauty products for white woman's
hair and said I think that there's an
entire market for African American hair
products she built that a fun fact this
CJ Walker was actually the name of her
husband but she took Sarah Breedlove why
they didn't have the same last name who
knows but long story short is she built
a massive company I went through a lot
of hardship and ended up being the first
female millionaire my favorite part of
the story and I don't know if this is
real or not or just Ramana is real so
people kept asking her like why do you
want why are you so ambitious what what
are you trying to do here she's like I
want to be wealthier than I think was
Rockefeller Carnegie and JP Morgan
combined she's just a baller
and she eventually got so wealthy that
she moved in next door to john d
rockefeller in new york was pretty good
so go watch it on Netflix self-made
promises where there was a four-part
series yeah it's very very good it's not
as crazy as a tiger King but definitely
worth it I think we enjoyed it and
anytime we can find things that both of
us like usually other people like it too
all right moving on to the real news
hard-hitting facts on lunch money Airbnb
what's going on there everybody was
supposed to go public in 2020 but those
plans were kind of derailed by
coronavirus so now everybody when it
raised 1 billion dollars in new funding
can you just like do that what's up well
okay so a couple of things sorry first
of all air baby's entire business is
getting demolished right now because no
is traveling so no one's traveling then
obviously they don't need a place to
stay and so they've got hosts that are
freaking out and then they've got very
little revenue coming in given that this
is a global pandemic and so previously
they had touted the fact that that a
billion dollars of cash from the balance
sheet they were going public they were
you know economic positive and there was
a really good position and they were
kind of the poster child for strong
balance sheets now all of a sudden what
we see is wait a second when revenue
goes to zero very quickly it looks like
maybe you don't really have a stronger
balance sheet as you thought supposedly
that they were actually gonna be okay
and they did have cash on hand but they
raised this billion dollars as a way to
kind of shore up the balance sheet give
people confidence and also I believe
they lowered the valuation a little bit
little down round action well from 31 to
26 billion so they still are a
multi-billion dollar company but
reportedly but to lose about five
billion dollars of valuation that's
pretty big step down true um do you
think that they'll go public above or
below the 26 billion dollar number below
below I think you're wrong wait when do
you think they'll go public
exactly I don't think they'll go public
now for probably two to three years
until we get out on the other side of
this and therefore the business will be
Brian Chesky is notorious for saying
like we raise money but we keep it all
in the bank we have enough we're not
using it whatever but like I'm not sure
I believe it and also right now with
everything that's going on they're
literally hopes I mean people are
cancelling left or right and there are
two parts so one they definitely did in
the past where they had raised like they
had a billion dollars of cash they had
never touched it like that was
definitely the state of their business
now that's not the case on top of that
we both know multiple people who rent
out properties on Airbnb and like it's
not just hey for the month of March
service cancellations or April people
are canceling all the way out through
like the end of the summer which is a
huge issue oh yeah my mom doesn't mayor
B&B stuff and she even has somebody I
think in October that canceled who's
just like screw it I'm not even playing
this game so pretty crazy right all
right we work bang bang next topic we
need like the thing that moves so it
tells us where we are and like a little
timer to speed this up go ahead next
week can you make that noise again it's
like this that noise is also the same as
like when they're printing money go
ahead so we work we work special
committee as suing something after
stopping withdrew its three billion
dollar tender over if you remember we
talked about this a few episodes ago
yeah I mean everybody kind of knew this
was gonna happen right like it's kind of
like Softbank made a promise Softbank
did not do good on that promise so now
they're getting sued is that what
happens hot take soft things not gonna
lose okay because I think that there's
so many legal ease like legalese in the
contract as to what we workers gonna
have to do to get the actual deal done
that one of the intricacies it'll be
like a technicality so in the spirit of
the deal yes we will work is in the
right and that Softbank promised to do
the tender and now they're backing out
and like softbank's reputation is
probably going to take a hit here for
backing out of a deal but at the same
time when you go in front of a court of
law it's not about like the ethos or the
spirit of the deal it's all about the
technical language and my guess is that
there's enough
technicalities in there where Softbank
feels like the requirements for the
tender weren't met and therefore their
duties like they're not idiots they know
that they're gonna get sued if they do
this and they obviously feel strong
enough about it that they're gonna be
able to because we work obviously feels
like they can win in court so there's
disagreements you go for a referee it's
kind of when you and I disagree except
for I'm the referee and the participant
and I always win we need to it we need
to make our lunch money friends our
referee all right next topic mortgages
this is wild what's going on in the
mortgage world honestly I don't know I
think people are not they're requesting
to delay their mortgage payments okay so
everyone knows how a mortgage works you
owe money every month but what happens
if you lose your job revenue for your
business goes to zero there's all these
financial hardships there's things that
you can do in order to kind of relieve
some of that pressure so you can just go
to your landlord and say hey or to your
bank and say hey can I pay less money
right most of them will say no because
they have her business to run but some
of them might work with you then what
you can do is you can do things like
deferment say hey I'll still pay you the
same money right but can we just put it
out a little bit yes yeah yeah or
there's things like forbearance etc
right there's all these different
options that you have the government
before the stimulus package was signed
came in and decided that they were gonna
actually allow people to get mortgage
relief before the bill was signed right
so there's things that you could start
to do in order to get that relief now
what they're seeing though is what's the
number it's a 2,000 percent of borrowers
it the the mortgage payment relief has
jumped by two thousand percent the
number of applications meaning that
there's literally millions of people
running and saying I can't pay my
mortgage can you help me with my
mortgage keep my guess is that these
numbers are all residential not
commercial but we can forget that
because it's the Mortgage Bankers
Association and so my guess is that it's
all residential stuff it doesn't
actually include commercial commercials
a whole nother bucket but what ends up
happening here is then there's also
that are being implemented some of these
stimulus bills etc trying to help people
what ends up happening is there's a very
circular nature to it this is where we
get into a big conversation so here's
how the like what I call the circle of
life in the economy so I'm the employer
you're the employee right actually
you're the employer on the employee but
let's actually have a little more
accuracy here so you fire me and so when
you fire me I now don't have income but
I still have expenses in my life so I
have to buy food I maybe have a wife and
a child right and I've got to pay those
bills for my mortgage etc I can't pay my
mortgage because I don't have an income
R and I don't have a lot of savings so
then I go to the bank and I say hey can
you give me forbearance and deterrent
whatever if the bank says yes they
provide relief to me but then it applies
pressure to the bank right because
that's their business boss where the
revenue comes from and so if the bank
then says no to me it puts the hardship
on me so the government obviously wants
to help as many people as they can right
so they're gonna provide relief in
different areas they may say let's give
relief to people here let's give relief
to banks here etc but what happens is if
all of a sudden the bank said to
everyone will relieve you yeah now we
get a solvency - how long can the banks
go without revenue right if people
aren't using the banks if there's no
revenue coming in the door well how
what's the balance sheet of a bank look
like and obviously for the Bank of
America is that JPMorgan Chase is
accepted they're gonna be fine
but like the local community bank but
they don't have merely the balance sheet
that these big banks have and so what
you do is you get this like chain
reaction where just the simple act of
you firing me ends up putting pressure
all across the economy so one news flash
don't fire me ever and then - is now if
you're sitting there and the Federal
Reserve Treasury the government except
you're saying how do we systematically
provide relief to this system without
causing maximal damage or any damage and
the short answer is like there's no
magic bullet there is no answer right
it's not a black-and-white scenario with
a right or wrong answer it's all kind of
opinion and they gotta go test it to see
what happens good it's not looking good
and on top of all of this here's the
scary part is this is all the the
residential market well when you get
into the commercial market what happens
when all the rest all the stores in New
York City they don't come back
right so we're now let's call it three
weeks in it's a government mandated
shutdown here in the United States most
small businesses they're about to run
out of cash but they've got about three
weeks on average of cash in the bank so
once we get past this week now we get
into week four or five six seven a lot
of these small businesses are gonna run
out of money so they may get some relief
do like the payroll protection program
or other things but what's more likely
to happen is I don't know my guess right
now is at least 25% of businesses aren't
coming back in the small business sector
that number could rise even higher but
about 25 percent of the businesses that
you know in the small business are not
coming back
well that's bad because those owners
don't have income anymore those
employees aren't gonna have jobs to come
back to but on top of that now what
happens to those commercial real estate
landlords right they still have
mortgages to pay and they own a building
that was reliant on income from rent
from that tenant yeah but if that
tenants revenue dries up they thought -
oh the money so you have one or two
things either go to the bank get relief
right or go find more tenants but if
more of the businesses are contracting
what I think is actually gonna happen is
there's gonna be landlords that are
literally like like high-rises in New
York move in and I'll give you two
months free just to get started and like
we'll blend down the cost except I don't
think that on a net basis meaning that
let's say there's a hundred businesses
twenty-five hundred them go under ten
might get new ones might get created but
on the net basis you still lost fifteen
businesses right so like overall small
business or small businesses on a grid
are gonna shrink in the United States
over the next couple of years maybe two
three years but I do think that coming
out of this there will be a lot of great
businesses built I don't think right
this second is the time yet but there
will be a moment over the next two years
where it's gonna be a fantastic time to
start a small business and you'll be
able to grow very rapidly etc the whole
thing is what sector is that in when do
you start it you know what's the product
or service that you sell etc and there's
also the chance that coronavirus comes
back and we have to do this all over
again a few months right there's also
that risk so it's definitely a risk from
like a scientific standpoint or a health
standpoint I think that they're going to
be overly
just about that though song actually I
think the probability is low although
it's scientifically possible just
because they're gonna keep people in
quarantine like it's much easier to keep
people in quarantine for long periods of
time than it is to let them out and then
put them back in right like if they let
everyone out of quarantine which sounds
like this sounds like a sci-fi novel
we're literally in quarantine right like
hey or the government issued or ordered
us to go home if they let us out and say
go back home yeah people gonna be like
no you guys for the birds like no way
yeah like I didn't want to flick off the
camera but yeah like that's miss do the
reaction people gonna have it's like I'm
not going back in quarantine like I've
tasted freedom you're not putting me
back in right it's like Tigers baby
tiger King Joe exotic whoo now by the
way it's not on the list but Joe exotic
has contracted corona virus yes yes I
read it on the Internet it must be true
go google it real quick but that
definitely happened Joe exotic in prison
has contracted corona virus which tells
me that if the tiger in the Bronx Zoo
and Joe exotic has contracted corona
virus I kind of feel like it's pretty
crazy is it true click-click I'm almost
positive see we don't we're not prepared
well you see what happens too used to
come so prepared now all of a sudden
she's here with me [ __ ] isolation
Medical Center oh my god yeah I told you
and he's exacts forth husband a 24 year
old bartender told the New York Post
something okay all right moving on to
the last one stimulus what do we got
here so Japan issued which I learned is
less than what we should yeah have you
guys ever seen the gift of Ron Paul
words like it's happening he's going
like this that's basically what's
happening here I don't know Kermit the
Frog listen we're not going to talk
about different characters or things cuz
you keep exposing the fact that you
didn't watch Toy Story probably it's by
the same thing long story short is that
Japan is now
doing a trillion-dollar stimulus plan
the u.s. did two trillion dollars it's
not gonna be enough there's already talk
of another stimulus package in the
United States
Japan's trillion-dollar stimulus package
just got announced under a state of
emergency and so what ends up happening
is people in the United States have a
very global view of the world whoo time
out time out you see Joe with the
highlight under stimulus oh man I'm just
saying listen that you guys see that
real-time feedback right there improving
on-the-fly we are iterating and making
this better for people all right so what
ends up happening is that Japan's
trillion-dollar stimulus plus the u.s.
is 2 trillion that's three trillion
dollars that's two countries in the
world there's a hundred eighty-six
everyone is gonna do every central bank
has to inject liquidity into the world
to get their markets to continue to go
and the idea is when you're in a
deflationary environment eating that
your currency is getting stronger asset
prices going down you overwhelm the
system with dollars or yen or you know
whatever your currency is and when you
do that then you should stabilize asset
prices that measure they recover but on
a global basis there's gonna be tens of
trillions of dollars printed injected
into the system and so it ends up
happening is the bottom 50% of people
people living paycheck to paycheck or
only holding cash are gonna get
decimated this is horrible for that and
what happened if you go long term if you
go back to 2008 and you look at the
income inequality you just see it go
like this right and the rich get richer
and the poor get poorer and it's all
because of the monetary stimulus that
happens so what this really reminds
people is the u.s. there's only one part
of the global economic system and yes
the US dollar is the global reserve
currency but we also are seen trillions
of dollars printed in other economies as
well and when you add it all up the US
will be a big part of it but it's not
the holistic picture and so people just
have to remember that the entire world
is about to get absolutely inundated
with new currency or new liquidity
injected into the system so interesting
crazy right
it says that okay this is the newest
package is equal to 20% of Japan's
economic output yeah GDP the US is
higher than that right now but they will
this second this stimulus package alone
yeah it's nine hundred ninety billion oh
so it's just under a trillion
but it's 20% of their GDP ethic so what
does the meet link that means that so
think of your business
think of your a business like this is a
high over generalization but if if we
had a piece of shop right and our output
equaled meaning our revenue yeah just
imagine if our output equaled a hundred
dollars right and now all of a sudden we
say you know what we're gonna create our
own currency and we're gonna print $20
of it 20% of all of the output was in
this new printed thing that's basically
what they've done here right is they're
saying at nine hundred ninety billion
dollars is 20% of their entire GDP which
is wild because in the US if you look at
like the balance sheet and how much
stimulus etc very quickly we're gonna
tip over it over fifty percent of GDP
and when you tip over fifty percent GDP
there's an argument are you still
capitalistic slide here capitalism
socialism communism we should there's a
little slope his opinions on communism
polina's dad's from Bulgaria he's a
gangster I don't know if he's I don't
know if the people are ready for please
dad
all right any any last things now that
we got the highlight I'm hype about the
- I feel like Joe has put us into a game
this thing pops up can you just like
make your notifications go away during
this period of time so we don't have why
would I put my notifications away then I
wouldn't get notified that's the whole
point
no I need the audiovisual notification
because sometimes you're not looking at
the screen you know you hear the little
noise it's kind of like an alarm clock
you know like when I wake up in the
morning and you get annoyed it's because
the alarm clock goes off you ever seen
the YouTube video where it's like
[Applause]
somebody or something
whistle tips go on YouTube and goo and
YouTube whistle tips it's the greatest
video on the internet all right we gotta
go it's been a pleasure lunch money
while wall she's trying to get rich the
rest of us trying to get our lunch money
right polina go sign up or read the
profile com she now owes us snacks money
or something for the advertiser
and we will see you guys tomorrow